jean loup s'il vous plaît jean-louis 900
éleveurs producteurs de viande bovine
avec genci oui ben moi c'est louis rossi
du loiret nourrir il est moyen oui
depuis très longtemps avant pour nous
booster pour les gens c'est de les
boucher qui sont attaqués par ces bons
centres weygand là un cac qui a les
sites harraga qui fait le show that were
tomber ça normal vous vous faites du bio
jean loup est ce que vous pouvez nous
montrer comment voilà c'est oui oui
coûter mais c'est pas compliqué nous les
les bétons on vit avec tout le temps
qu'on sent le tube comme il faut mon
dieu mais il ya un animal ils sont
nourris au point et qu'on leur fait un
complément en fait pour tourner ce soir
il ya un ananas qui sort directement ou
non s'est passé c'est pour ce à quoi
vont expliquer ces bons coups piquée 1
le foot c'est bien mais ça suffit pas il
faut leur donner un comparatif montrez
moi mais j en grèce et au procès s'est
jamais mon mac certes je sais que j'ai
bricolé avec un oui mais oui mais de la
haine du blé tout ça et moi de récupérer
des les invendus de légumes là que fais
tu as écouté ça se met là dedans
voyez la donne et après ils patates et
apprécions l'appui les pipes cible un
lien tuyaux et ça envoie énormément joué
[Musique]
[Rires]
s'intéresser à vous tous merci